welcome back well then just over a
hundred days the UK will face an ex
brexit deadline and both candidates have
said they want to see a new deal done in
that time but is it possible well
joining us now is the brexit secretary
Stephen Bach
thank you for being on the show you this
morning sparkly good morning
so have you picked up any shift in that
you use position particularly Ireland's
position recently well there's a
positive tone struck by Soviet Simon
Kony in the press this morning
clearly the EU recognized it's in their
interest to avoid a new deal a new deal
outcome will be very damaging across the
EU and so both sides want to secure a
deal and it will be the task of new
prime minister to have those discussions
but I think the EU recognize it's in
both sides interest to get to that
outcome it's been reported that you told
the EU exit negotiator Michele Barnea
five times in a recent meeting that is
dead now I'm sure you won't comment on
private meetings but in your view is the
withdrawal agreement dead well it
certainly wouldn't need to make the same
point five times in the same meeting so
I think that gives you a clue but what I
said is exactly what I said to the
Select Committee and no one on the
Select Committee which is across party
committee and members of parliament
disagreed which is that the current text
are the withdrawal agreement if nothing
at all is changed then I didn't see that
going through the House of Commons it's
been rejected three times since then
we've had the European elections where
if anything the houses further polarized
and so what I was very openly and
honestly sharing with them was an update
on the political scene in London and I
think if the text isn't changed in any
way it's difficult to envisage how that
will go through the House of Commons so
if - if the withdrawal agreement is dead
if the EU is saying that it's not like
open for renegotiation that it does look
as if we could be heading towards a No
Deal brexit if Boris Johnson becomes
Prime Minister and has determined to
take the UK out by that deadline in
October now that is something the
Chancellor says will cost the UK 90
billion pounds is that a price west pain
well the figure you quote relates to a
Treasury forecast for 2035
a full 15 years after the end
of the implementation period and it also
assumes that the government would take
absolutely no action in response to a
new deal well as the Chancellor knows
and as I know there are teams currently
working in the Treasury on exactly what
options we will take if we were in the
position of a No Deal outcome so those
teams wouldn't be working in the way
they are if the intention of the
government was not to take action so so
there is a forecast there there's a load
of forecasts that are being put out in
recent weeks the reality is a No Deal
would be disruptive but we've got over
300 teams across writer working on our
preparations whilst it remains our
priority to secure a deal if the EU are
willing to move on that it's not just
any forecast though is it it's a cross
government forecast including by your
department that you actually present a
department in that was published by your
your department in November I mean
surely we have to try no it wasn't
presented by myself and what I'm saying
is it's a forecast that's based on no
action being taken by government when I
think everyone including the Chancellor
would accept that in the event of nadir
then of course the government would take
action and it's also a a forecast to
2035 which I think your viewers will
know any forecast 15 years after the
implementation period can only be
treated it with a certain degree of
questioning so so there are limits to
what can be forecast we know that from
each budget the issue is what action
would the government take in the event
of no deal own across government we're
preparing
extremely seriously to ensure that the
new Prime Minister has the options he
needs now you of course are looking
after you
preparations for no deal it's something
that we know Boris Johnson would like to
see a big advertising campaign around to
make sure that businesses are prepared
in your view our business is doing
enough to make sure they can mitigate
any problems associated with an Oda
brexit well I think what Boris
absolutely gets is there's a difference
between the preparation of many large
firms and the current position of many
other small and medium-sized firms I
think just as government has over 300
teams working on this a lot of large
firms have been working for several
years to prepare an AIF allocates at
such as the pharmaceutical sector a huge
amount of work has been done I think
where things are not as advanced is in
the small business sector where many
small businesses here
members of parliament hear the message
coming out of Parliament where people
say that no deal will be taken off the
table and therefore assume that they
don't need to prepare and that's the
particular area where we will need to
focus our communications moving forward
what kind of things should businesses be
doing should they be looking at
stockpiling at for example well the
border flow you only need to stop pile
if there's issues for example at the
short streets between Dover and Calais
and a huge man named the French have put
in well we expect some description but
far less than was envisaged in March so
the the forecasts have improved
considerably so it's a mix between
stockpiling flow and what are other
options we can take and that's exactly
the sort of thing we've been looking at
in our preparations having a lot of
roundtables a lot of meetings with
industry in order to get that right but
there'll be a mix between stockpiling
but also in terms of how we get goods
through the container ports or action we
take at Dover Calais the French
authorities have also taken action but
Sophie this isn't just a UK problem
around 40% of islands exports go through
Dover so it's not just UK goods that
would be stuck at Dover it would also be
the goods of EU 27 member states and in
particular the Irish would be acutely
affected if there were delays there so
this is a shared challenge and that's
why it's in both sides interest to come
to sensible early reciprocal
arrangements to keep the flow of goods
moving through the short straits
according to the Sunday Times if there
is a no deal then
medicines will be prioritized traveling
through daiva followed by medical
equipment and then fresh food is that
right yeah we've said that repeatedly
and anything that's a revelation
category one goods
first and foremost start with medicines
there be some different products as well
a huge amount of work has gone in by the
Department of Health and Social Care on
that working with the pharmaceutical
industry and we're in very good shape in
terms of the work that's gone on
particularly within that that's also why
we put in place and we had a written
ministerial statement in Parliament a
couple of weeks ago 8th
framework to enable us to procure
additional capacity should that be
necessary
in the autumn we're acutely aware that
it's essential that we maintain the flow
of medicines through the short straights
but again there's actually more
medicines that go out to Europe from the
UK then come in from Europe into the UK
so this is again a shared issue that
it's in both size interest to get right
and how should we as individuals be
preparing for the thought of an ideal
break sir I mean are we safe to book
holidays you know in Europe in the
autumn or would you really because this
is a the the Commissioner made clear
that they see continuity I mean you
don't need me to tell you Sophie that
for the hoteliers for the tourist trade
in many European Member States that this
is an issue that they want to maintain
the continuity approach and this is
exactly the sort of areas we've been
discussing there's already continuity
arrangements for example on flights but
also this is where we need to move
forward on things like data because in
terms of data around holidays it's in
the European firms interest to have
arrangements to enable data to be shared
as well so many of these issues are
reciprocal they affect the EU 27 member
states as well as the UK and it's
important was continuing to work towards
a deal that as part of our new deal
preparation we get sensible reciprocal
arrangements in place because it's in
the EU sinteres just as it is in the
UK's interest that doesn't always mean
it happens though does it even if both
sides want something so let me let me
give you an example just last week a
signing a deal with the Swiss
authorities in terms of workers being
able to move from the UK to Switzerland
and vice-versa a couple of weeks ago
signing a deal with their Luxembourg
prime minister in terms of voting rights
in Luxembourg got similar arrangements
in Spain and Portugal if you look at
health for example at one point five
percent of the Irish health budget is
from the NHS they make a net three
hundred million pounds from the UK in
terms of health spend so my point is
it's in both size interest to come to
sensible early deals in terms of no deal
but obviously we're still working to try
and reach a deal and both leadership
content contenders both Boris and Jeremy
have said that is their first priority